it is great to be joined today by Carl
cederstrom who's associate professor at
Stockholm Business School at Stockholm
University also author of the book The
Happiness fantasy Carl it's so great to
talk to you today and we're going to
talk about an issue that sort of relates
to an interview we did yesterday
actually about how corporations and tech
billionaires have in many ways co-opted
what is sort of safe activism activism
they're okay with but that doesn't
really challenge the status quo and sort
of related to that is the idea of the
concept of happiness in Western society
and how that also has been significantly
influenced by the idea of happiness that
is sort of useful or beneficial to
corporations so can we talk about that a
little bit and maybe first to begin with
even more generally when we talk about
measuring happiness what are we really
measuring how can we do that what are
some of the methods that exist well
there are a lot of methods out there but
briefly I would say that we don't really
know what we measure apart from what
people believe to be happiness at that
particular moment and they've done
really fascinating studies where they
just make very very minor changes to the
configuration or the setting of one of
these sort of happiness survey settings
and you can see that the change of the
result is very significant but let's say
if you go back 2,000 years and hand out
one of those happiness surveys you're
probably going to find about the same
result that you get today I mean the
average score is usually 7.5 from 1 to
10 point scale and what we lack is a
definition of happiness or rather we
have too many definitions of happiness
we've got millions of different
definitions and and it's because
happiness is a philosophical question
and we don't know what it is and I'm
afraid to say that we're never going to
fully find out what it is because it's
basically tantamount to something as
elusive as what does it mean to live a
good meaningful life so when we in
thinking about the difficulty of actual
coming up with it's one sort of stable
definition over a long period of time of
what we mean can you talk a little bit
about how the perception of what
happiness is has shifted in human
history just to sort of and introduce
that idea to the conversation what are
sort of aspects of happiness that might
have been prevalent thousands of years
ago that maybe no longer are today well
I think the major shift we see in the
Enlightenment because it's only then
that happiness becomes something that
we're not only supposed to strive
towards but something that we should
attain prior to that point happiness was
something that we couldn't really
achieve as human beings it was basically
to reserve of the gods this was the idea
of happiness in ancient Greece for
instance you should pursue happiness
which to the Greek
Greeks was the same as trying to become
an ethical human being and develop a set
of virtuous faculties and you know
during the Middle Ages in Christianity
happiness didn't really exist in the
life on earth it was something that you
would get when you were dead for having
done your duty on on earth so it's
really only in the Enlightenment that we
get happiness is something that we are
able to attain but even up to the you
know the beginning of the 20th century
half this was still regarded as
something that was very very difficult
if not impossible to achieve what you
would find in worked from Freud's is
only really in the 1950s that we begin
to have this idea that happiness is
something that everyone could achieve
and in the 1950s the idea of happiness
in the United States in particular was
very closely bound up with the happy
housewife who would spend her days with
the kids and our husband who would go to
work and then come home and ask for a
whiskey and the family would be all
happy together so it was a sense of
happiness built around the family and
security and then of course just a
decade after in the 1960s that changes
in a very very drastic manner when
happiness is by no means to be sort or
searched for within the family but
instead something that I was about
breaking free from the different norms
and you know the kind of chains of
societies it was then we're closely
connected to personal liberation
personal growth and living a life in
freedom so it would it be fair to say
that we'll get to the more recent impact
of consumer culture on the pursuit of
happiness but before we step into that
would it be fair to say that happiness
may be longer ago was considered more of
a process whereas now or it shifted more
recently to something that you can kind
of achieve and that's it you've done it
and the the chapter is sort of closed I
think it's fair to say that and and
obviously today everyone is selling and
offering happiness in all its forms we
even have you know something you can
drink that would offer you happiness or
you're supposed to get happiness from
from anything so yeah I think that's
fair to say it had a much more long-term
process perspective in the past and it
has now so then we can now introduce the
idea of consumer culture and products
and services and wellness and all of
this other stuff have we seen a decline
in self-reported happiness in the time
period since this consumer culture has
developed and if so is it more acute in
certain countries than in others it's
impossible to say if the happiness level
when you search when you look at that
would have decreased or increased
because as I said at the outset if you
do this service you would tend to get
pretty much the same kind of asks if you
only focus on what people say when they
are being asked are you happy or not but
I think it's fair to say that the
society will live in today where so many
people are living on a very very little
money and they are living under
precarious circumstances and they feel a
great degree of anxiety and the rest of
it I think it's fair to say that this is
sense of unhappiness that has been very
widespread and which I would argue is
strongly connected to material
circumstances people not being able to
create a life that they are at the same
time being promised I think the crucial
point now is that we're still being sold
this idea that everyone could become a
great success story through a kind of
personal growth trajectory where you end
up actualizing yourself but then at the
same time you could see statistically
that so many people are think something
up to a third of the American population
were under the poverty level for two
months between 2009 and 2011 so I think
it's a very kind of cruel vocabulary and
Sharan that we find not least among
politicians who would say that everyone
could be happy if only they tried hard
enough and yet at the same time we know
that those same people or very many
people in a way are living on the very
unhappy circumstances so it seems like
there's sort of three ideas that I want
to broach now and see what you think of
them which one is maybe more or less
important or just kind of get your
thoughts here number one is that
statistically most people are not going
to be sort of at the top when it comes
to income when it comes to well bright
like mathematically speaking the 1% is
only 1% of the population so that that's
sort of one problem in terms of
expectations number two is this concept
of hedonic adaptation which is that once
you achieve a new level of status money
personal items that you now own and have
access to a bigger house a more
expensive car you very quickly become
acclimated to that it becomes your new
baseline and you're not actually any
happier than you were when that's what
you were striving for long ago and then
number three that I would introduce is
the idea that a lot of happiness or
satisfaction is dictated not actually by
what you have or have achieved but how
it compares to what others around you
have achieved and that's sort of where
we get into a conversation about
inequality and the negative impacts of
that these three issues is there one in
your mind that you think
most important have I mentioned
something that you don't think is
important I think probably the first one
is the one that speaks to me most
directly and the reason for that is the
way we think about happiness today is so
deeply influenced by self-help
literature and a self-help culture that
has really came to come to dominate our
lives and there is one self-help book
which is very well known called the
secret where there's a collection of
voices who would explain what a secret
is basically it's having find this law
of attraction which means that if you
just put your mind to it in the right
way you will be able to govern your life
and everything that happens to you
through your own thought patterns and
they do say at one point there's only 1%
of the people who have really figured
out the secret so in other words and the
point I'm trying to make here is that
the kind of self-help culture that has
come to define happiness for us today is
really trying to Deepa little eyes our
surroundings our circumstances the lives
we live and basically say that anyone
could be happy but probably just about
1% because it's only really those 1% who
have put their mind to it and that means
that the 99% who don't have the same
degree of power and wealth just have
themselves to blame and that is the kind
of rhetoric that has become so prevalent
and dominant in our a notion of
happiness and and that is something I
find really problematic so let's now
introduce into this how corporations
have sort of guided and defined the
image of happiness that we have really
for their own benefit right for the
benefit of selling the product or
service that they offer we can either
I if you have specific examples that's
great if you want to talk a little more
generally about the role of the
corporation and in public relations and
advertising in guiding what we see is
happiness either way I think that that's
the next idea to introduce
yes I mean we could see a very
significant shift taking place in the
1970s so if the 1960s was a decade where
a lot of people did want to break free
from the demands they had felt
previously that they had to live this
very boring secure life then in the
1970s a lot of corporations were
struggling to find ways of making work
appetizing and especially to try and
attract young talented people to the
workplace and you had several business
gurus who hit upon what they thought was
a brilliant idea at the time which was
that corporations and executives should
start using the vocabulary of the 1960s
they were Cabul era of authenticity or
liberation of freedom and so in the
1970s more and more corporations really
started to pick up on this language and
then in the 1980s you could see how the
really successful personal growth
centers started to design courses
especially designed for executives and
HR people so people would leave their
offices and they would go on these
retreats to find themselves but also to
find ways of becoming more successful at
their work so you would find how the
kind of spirit of personal growth
self-actualization and finding inner
meaning became so repackaged as a way of
also becoming better and plead and
interestingly in the 1980s you would
find some really well-known corporations
including IBM and Louis Strauss using
the exact same words and phrases that
were developed in the 1960s around a
human potential movement and human
potentiality first coined by Aldous
Huxley who was probably most known for
the book brave new world but also for
experimenting with psychedelic drugs and
being a little pioneer in the nineteen
sixties movement of spiritual awakening
and all the rest of that and and other
things are also happening in
1970s you would find personal growth
seminars becoming wildly popular there's
one of them that I write about in a book
I started by a man called Werner Erhard
it's of name that he took the seminar
centers called s Erhard seminars raining
people winter for weekend long training
and what we were being taught
specifically was that there are no
victims in the world and also if they
only found the right way of thinking
about the reality and themselves they
would be able to come back and change
their lives around so you could become
the person they really wanted to be and
so this is really a story it's only real
it's really under intense in ninth and
eighth it's a lot of corporations start
to pick up on that and then in the 1990s
we had the big boom of corporate
cultures and this has really is an
ongoing trend that we could see today
really how it has culminated in some
really bizarre in some really bizarre
examples so for instance there's a UK
sandwich selling fast food chain where
the employees basically the people who
stand by the cashier and sell sandwiches
are expected not just to be happy but to
be authentically happy and there are
cases how employees have been
disciplined when they haven't lived up
to this I think when it's come to that
point the Corporations giving a minimum
wage or close to to their employees and
forcing them not just to smile but to
had that sense of I am a liberated free
authentic human being there's something
that isn't quite right and that really
is the bottom line of what what I try to
tell in this book the history from how
the idea of self-actualization is human
potentiality which made a lot of sense
as a form of happiness in the 1960s if
you saw the contrast to the 1950s and
how people felt really regulated and and
suppressed you could see how from the
1960 to today the notion of happiness
and self actualization have
really been very important tools for
politicians and corporations but what
him but the result is that this is not I
think I kind of happiness that one could
truly believe in yeah I mean the the
mandating of authentic happiness reminds
me of a scene in the film office space
office space where the Jennifer Aniston
character is told she doesn't have
enough pieces of flair on her uniform
and she says well how many pieces do you
want me to have and the manager says
it's not about how many I want you to
have it's I want you to want to have
more pieces of flair on your uniform and
it's that idea of sort of mandating a
certain type of authenticity very very
interesting we've been speaking with
Karl cederstrom who's an associate
professor at Stockholm Business School
in Stockholm University the book is the
happiness fantasy which I encourage you
to check out Karl thanks so much for
talking to me today thank you my
pleasure to be on the show